Mm,
so when we think about democracy,
I think there's kind of a real
interesting opportunity to think about
what is participatory democracy in the
modern connected,
connected world and I think there's all
kinds of versions that are much better
than the vote every two years kind of
version that we have right now.
For example,
does a lovely experiment that said,
what if people got to vote on,
we're five percent of their income tax
goes to.
So you will get the list of all the
things the government does,
right?
Which is actually already a good thing
because people don't know what the
government does.
We went at some point,
we went to the Chapel Hill Public
Library and we ask people when was the
last time you got benefit from tax
payers money?
People couldn't remember when was the
last time and they were in a public
library funded by taxpayers money.
So you know,
we don't really understand what the
government does,
what,
what taxes go for,
but if you've got a list of all the
things the government does and you could
decide five percent,
you know,
you probably don't want people to
allocate all of their income tax because
there's some things that the government
needs to worry about,
but doing some kind of marginal
contribution and thinking where we want
to be,
I think would get people to be more
involved,
care more,
look at waste.
I think it will make government officers
a bit more accountable.
So that's one version where I think we
could get participatory democracy to be
closer to what we wanted,
wanted to be.
And another,
another kind of direction is to say why
do we need to vote for one person?
Right?
So,
so imagine that we will have a voting
procedure.
We would say you could say I want then
Ben really to vote for me on any issues
that has to do with education and
health,
but not about a,
I don't know,
space exploration and not about a
nuclear activities.
You can imagine all of society is a
network of people and you can assign
your vote,
not just to the representatives,
but you could assign your votes to other
people in society where you could say,
you know,
what,
then I trust you or those topics you
could vote for me and I can trust
somebody else.
And so on.
So we could,
we could create a network in which we
trust different people for different
subtopics and not have this idea that is
one person who is representing us is,
is the right person for all,
all topics around.
So,
um,
so that's one.
The other,
the other,
of course,
a big issue.
Um,
I don't know if you saw this,
but we,
we need it,
although studies about how people want
society to be designed.
So originally we did it on inequality,
financial inequality,
but then we moved to other areas as
well,
but in the area,
financial inequality.
And we ask people,
first of all,
what they understand about the
distribution of wealth in the US.
So we said,
imagine if we took all the people in the
US from the cruise to the riches.
We broke them into five buckets,
the 20 percent richest,
20 percent less,
less,
less than the poorest,
and we asked you from the 100 percent
wealth total time how much is allocated
right now to each of those five buckets,
and people think that the bottom two
buckets,
the bottom 40 percent of Americans own
about nine percent of the wealth when in
fact they own about zero point three,
right?
So the,
the,
this slope is what's called the Gini
Coefficient.
The rate of inequality.
People know the rich have.
A lot of people don't understand the
American don't understand how much
little the poor,
the poor half.
And then we also ask them what would you
like society to be?
And we use a John Roles.
If you remember John Rawls had this
interesting idea that he said a just
society is a society that if you knew
everything about it,
you will be willing to join it in a
random place.
But if you're very rich,
you might want society that treats the
regionalized and the not so nice.
If you're very poor,
you might want the other way around,
but if you don't know where you'll be,
you'll be allocated after the fact.
You have to consider all perspective.
And he called this developer ignorance
because you choose before you know where
you'll be.
So we described the veil of ignorance to
lots of people and we say,
what kind of society would you like to
create?
And Americans created a society that is
more equal than Sweden,
not perfectly equal.
Nobody wants socialism,
but much more equal than than Sweden.
And not only that,
the differences between Republicans and
Democrats were tiny.
So you know,
Republicans want in slightly more
inequality.
Democrats won in slightly more equality,
but it was small difference compared to
the gap between what we have and what
people want.
And that's another way to think about
democracy in the modern world.
So,
you know,
you could say that we could vote on a
topic like we could vote on whether we
want Obama's healthcare version.
That's,
that's one approach.
But,
but to vote on that as individual,
just way too complex,
this plan is,
I mean,
includes so much.
We're not going to be experts on it.
We don't have the time to really read
the whatever,
7,000 pages of this plan.
What what we could do is we could vote
on our principles,
on how we want society to be right,
not about the concrete aspects,
but on what,
what are the guiding principles of
society,
how much we care about equality and how
much we care about access to health and
not to vote on something concrete,
but to vote on it in terms of what are
the principles we believe in and then it
will be the job of the politicians to
take our principles and translate them
into policies.
Think about something like investment.
If you go to a an investment
professional to help you,
they don't ask you what stocks you want
to invest in.
That's their job.
What they ask you is what can I firstly
want to take?
How much money do you want to give to
charity?
They ask you again of the general
principles about life and then they go
ahead and figure how those principles
are going to be played out in the
details and.
And that's another kind of interesting
version to think about politics,
which you say we as citizens will never
have the expertise to truly vote on
everything,
but we understand our own values and we
can say what kind of society do we want
to,
to create?
And it will be the job of the
politicians to take these values and
translate them into specific instances
and rules.